[Music]
in rise and shine news morning-time
submitted by bonjour from france i know
i pronounced that wrong uh yeah I do
actually
hold on hold a psychologist shares a
science back 7 step formula that can
turn anyone into a morning person oh you
know what's crazy so last night right I
was like I just had one of those tossing
and turning I can't go to sleep nights
where it's like I went to sleep at like
midnight
I [ __ ] tossed and turn and thought
about like you know getting kidnapped I
thought about a black helicopter flying
over your house like I've been watching
this game like you know when you watch
people play video games those
walkthroughs and stuff I'm really on
Yakuza right now it's pretty dope the
game is literally like it's like it's
like a drama and you just fight your way
everything is you fight like that's your
answer to everything like these guys
don't like your crew you fight like you
have to prove your innocence you fight
you want people to believe you you fight
so then everything is like I go to sleep
thinking okay to solve my issues I have
to fight I have to defeat all my enemies
and I'm like thinking there and it's
2:40 and I'm like damn it I can't go to
sleep I'm gonna have the worst day
tomorrow go to sleep I wake up at 8
today and I'm like oh my god I feel like
amazing I don't know how that happened
so I only slept like 4 or 5 hours you're
probably eating Oh Jesse you're sleeping
[ __ ] like oh yeah maybe like 10 Jessa's
no I thought I was I mean I just had the
greatest morning it was it was weird the
greatest morning this is amazing like I
feel relieved I feel like I just I just
went to the sauna and then like I got
out and I feel like fresh and it was
great for hours asleep was awesome you
just gotta think about fighting for two
hours and I maybe because I
himself fell yeah put a TV back in my
room it wasn't a good idea because I'm
watching no you [ __ ] uh what's it
called lost and I said I know I started
to realize I was like oh that's right
those are right or strike after like
what happened you mean save you a lot of
time right now I'll save you a lot of
time right no I saw before
oh you know there's gonna so I only went
up to the where the writer strike was
and then now I'm like watching it I'm
like look at Doug do you want to know
what what is all the dream sorry the cat
like [ __ ] died what died on the OH
spoiler alert if you ever even watched
it by now sorry
yeah or something like that so so this
behavioral psychologist named Joe
hemming publishes seven step formula and
so with the same I'm gonna say all seven
and then I'm gonna go into each one so
number one sleeping on the left side of
the bed
two wearing something yellow in bed
three setting your alarm for your
favorite feel-good song for sex or
exercise when you wake up for five
minutes doing a headstand for two
minutes stairs the color green for ten
minutes this is like a step by step it's
not like pick one out of the seven I'm
not sure the way they wrote this is kind
of a better be pink one yeah
ice-cold shower three minutes seven slow
energy release breakfast for five
minutes so wait this is a breakfast very
slowly I miss I guarantee you the sex
part is I go right back to sleep
afterwards I can't [ __ ] in the morning I
do it and I'm asleep for three more
hours I need to retry
like I need to replenish my ballsack
sorry river that when it says morning is
the best time of the day to have sex not
only does it boost your immune system
and release oxytocin to make you more
relaxed a quickie in the morning will
set you up for the day if I got [ __ ] to
do that day
I love morning sex man jacking off count
I hate morning release is the same thing
no that's the only time energy is in the
morning I do that night I'm tired man
how like because everybody's smelling
everybody smelling like something that's
true and it's like hey can we yell both
go brush our teeth first it's like
that's really not the [ __ ] move right
so I'm like morning sex I think that's
your not making love you're just doing
some hard [ __ ] right your wife is a
lucky woman just [ __ ] take that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Jaime's wearing white shirt on a [ __ ]
horse that's the kind where you're not
face to face yes it'd be like your
mouth-closed looting [ __ ] yeah I have
to brush my teeth right when I wake up
in the morning I have to say this is a
must just because it smells so bad
I can feel bad for myself the weird
thing about me is like even if I'm still
sleepy if I wake up I just brush my
teeth at go back cuz it just tastes so
better dozen the next time you wake up
your breath stinks again but it's not
anywhere as bad it was before though
that [ __ ] is horrendous I just drink
water I forget remember that day we were
in Hawaii I didn't [ __ ] shower for
like four days straight
yes oh [ __ ] like every day if you go to
the oceans a little bit yeah I'm
no cuz I go into ocean and then like I
go in the pool and then I'm like Sivir
where's that fluorine all over you put
that much in but the chlorines is
actually good because the chemicals kill
all the nasties in your skin you have
excellent I know but it got better next
when they say get the heartbeat going
and feel good hormones flowing with just
five minutes of stretching which will
release serotonin the happy hormone I
thought this [ __ ] list was gonna be
stuff you do the night before not one
you [ __ ] wake up no [ __ ]
if you wake up and you're running around
you're gonna be away right I get this
cuz I'm one of those people I'm just not
a morning person so if I would do any
one of these things I feel you would
definitely but the trick is to get out
of bed in the first place yeah I think
that's the biggest hump that anyone has
know cuz for me I will get up take Isaac
to school in the morning come back and
go back to sleep like me just getting up
- how about on vacations girl what about
the kitchen when you go on vacations
aren't you a morning person
oh yeah yeah six o'clock in the morning
ready to explore the new city did you
pay for that [ __ ] I'm a hundred percent
a morning person if I'm like somewhere
like 6 a.m. the stores got open what the
[ __ ] like I gotta get out of here I got
to do stuff you know yeah if it was like
if I don't get to a certain place I lose
$100 then I'm up every time yeah that's
another and this whole list is [ __ ]
anyway all you need like if you really
want to be a morning person is have a
[ __ ] hire a guy to [ __ ] get a
megaphone and you wake your ass up like
every day for like two weeks and you'll
be [ __ ] scared like in the morning to
go wake up like that's what happened my
brothers they went to boot camp and now
they're both morning people and they
were [ __ ] the traumatised this way is
just to not be a curious person just be
stupid as [ __ ] then you don't have to
like research it at night for [ __ ]
reason that's super
I the other night I spent like [ __ ]
three hours like researching stargates
because it's like a [ __ ] thing you
know people are like it stargates is a
thing you can put you good yesterday
night I was looking up like some more
film equipment even though I don't film
anything in a while and I started
looking up different types of lights and
I was like oh man like look at this new
tip and I they built up my [ __ ] cart
to be about $20,000 I was like I gotta
buy this but it was 5 a.m. right there
vlog you're shopping like you should
just start vlogging that time that
you're on Amazon just didn't it crazy
like my my shopping cart for my [ __ ]
it's all stuff I will never be able to
afford I was like man I should just get
rid of all my camera quit just buy the
ones that I need it turns out that's
just like $70,000 and I'm like saving
for later but [ __ ] like this is why
every time I might get a party or
something in people like oh I'm so busy
like how about you you really busy and
I'm like thinking like I just spent 3
hours researching stargates and I'm like
yes full of [ __ ] everyone is like who
works on their [ __ ] 24 hours a day 7
days a week [ __ ] nobody I don't know
one person who does that [ __ ] in 2050 we
were actually really pretty bad yeah but
I think now we're busy and in
researching Stargate kinds of any of
these things that they mentioned this
morning absolutely how far did they come
they're 6 foot 5 is just I can crush my
spine down oh they're all the thing to
get blood flowing to your head instead
of like a headphone you can I pull your
hair this is like this is like when I
read story it's like it's like if you
were a vegan you wouldn't have to worry
about cholesterol I'm like well that's
not an option what are we talking about
right now like it doesn't like I'm not
gonna stop eating meat so stop telling
like like I'm not gonna [ __ ] do a
headstand before I go to bed so what are
we talking about right well when I got
out of it I'm not doing any of it or
pulling my little hairs like what is the
[ __ ]
honestly obviously what works for me
though is uh I just step outside and get
some sunlight oh yeah it does a lot it
really does a lot and I don't know why
it doesn't didn't work for me they
remember that one time in that small
period where we would wake up in the
morning go outside and have breakfast
yeah they go right back to bed oh how is
that possible I don't know how do you
guys sleep is my question cuz when I'm
laying down and I'm not in this state of
like pure exhaustion this thing is
[ __ ] just running like a [ __ ] like I
just want to get out of my body because
what I meditate I think about other [ __ ]
that's why it's like a process because
me too I because my dad told me did to
meditate and just start doing like
breathing exercises I cool how do I
start a fire if I was in this situation
I know it's like it's like okay I'm
gonna take okay hold on how do I
meditate I mean like that's what we all
do last night I was like I need to focus
on my breath and I was like oh stop
talking to me get up and just like call
myself like [ __ ] dude I gotta go on
Instagram man like call my mind let's
see that's what it is dopamine that you
get from your [ __ ] phone dude yeah
it's like it relaxes me and then I
started watching this documentary about
this Dutch banker whose whistle blowing
about the Illuminati and I went to sleep
like a baby
and you got to know something that'll
really help you with your life oh my god
I'm so awake I'm gonna try to sleep even
humanly Bob is a lucky dude I wish I
could do that that's like what that's my
one wish dude that's Nikki - she could
be driving a [ __ ] bulldozer and it's
like 11:59 midnight she's like
no no oh my god but come in the car -
I'm strapped in like it is tight yeah
it's just she just can't set him in
touch I do that - TIFF all the time if
you want to watch a movie let's watch a
movie we never watch a movie five
minutes and I'm not the only one
invested in the movie and I'm all awake
alone I'm like I hate you you do it to
me every time same for me same as I
should you can't fall asleep pretty
easily because I feel like all girls
just knock out like that mm-hmm
the range is always overworking not all
women are the same okay we'll leave this
guy every time he's on I can't [ __ ]
believe it's gone
what's up you sexy [ __ ] useless
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you want to
follow us you could check out all our
[ __ ] links in the description box
below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]